hey you guys it's max with Max Tech
today we're gonna do a camera comparison
between the new pixel 4 and the pixel 3
axl which is less than half the price
I'm starting off using the front-facing
camera both these can shoot 1080p at 30
frames per second you guys could tell
we'll audio that I'm using from each one
of these microphones as a little speaker
icon switches so let's go ahead and
start out by doing some walking here and
both of our mountain to the same
handheld rig so you guys can tell which
one I use has some better stabilization
and also a dynamic range up there in the
sky now I'm gonna go ahead and start
doing a limiter running in the comments
let's flip around here see how it does
with the shadows and highlights in this
bright Sun and now we're gonna switch to
their rear lenses here's a comparison of
flaring and dynamic range in the shadows
of that tree and then we could take a
look at details we're shooting 4k at 30
frames per second on both that is the
maximum that both of these can do and
then here we have some transitions with
more details and the pixel 4 can
actually zoom in 8 times as you guys can
see whereas the pixel 3 axl can only
zoom in 5 times so I'm gonna zoom back
out to match both of these and you guys
let me know which one looks better as
far as detail now let's zoom back out
and test out stabilization when we're
shooting 4k 30 frames per second so have
a light jog right now
let's turn around and now this is a
really fast running
and now we're testing out stabilization
when I am running starting off with the
sunrise that pixel four pushes up the
shadows a bit more and has less
saturation with a little bit more
flaring we see a similar result here
where the pixel for software is choosing
to have less saturation in contrast and
make the image a little bit brighter
here's a super-tough portrait shot the
pixel 4 does have a better algorithm for
cutting between the little sticks in
this bush and it doesn't an incredible
job for how difficult the scene is
here's a first shot comparing the new
added telephoto lens of the pixel 4
compared to the pixel 3 a's super or a
zoom digital crop and looking at it like
this you can't see that much of a
difference but if we punch in now it
could tell that the pixel 4 has a little
bit more detail and less artifacts
because it doesn't need to digitally
crop but it does have a little bit more
flaring here I switch to portrait mode
and as you could tell that the pixel 3a
wasn't able to capture a portrait shot
because it has a 2 time zoom and I had
to walk backwards and able to fit the
whole car into frame whereas the pics
before has a 1.5 times crop and I was
able to actually get it to work now if
we punch in another thing you'll clearly
notice is there's a lot more artifacting
and noise in the pixel 3/8 photo even
though the ISO as you could see is
basically the same that's because of the
extra crop we're only actually capturing
about 6 megapixels worth of data
compared to 9 the pixel 4 does still use
the super resume algorithm alongside its
telephoto lens and here we can see you
way more detail when I punch into 5x on
both of these which is the limit on the
3a and where the pixel 4 can actually
zoom in more if you would like well we
clearly see a big difference in detail I
was really surprised by this macro shot
they look pretty much identical with
both a lot of detail but the pixel 3a
actually did a better job with edge
detection for blur in this high dynamic
range scene both of them do an excellent
job
but we could see that the pixel 3a has a
little bit more contrast and saturation
just like the previous pixel phones
whereas the pixel 4 takes a different
approach pushing up the shot is a bit
more
and having more natural colors with a
little bit less saturation more similar
to an iPhone if we punch in we could see
that the actual detail and quality of
the image is basically identical this is
an extremely difficult portrait shot
where we deman standing in the shade and
they're super bright sunlight so very
high dynamic range scene I am very
impressed by how well they did and both
of them look super similar the pixel
four has slightly brighter shadows and
it's also slightly warmer in terms of
white balance changing the trend of the
previous pixel phones being slightly
cool we have the same exact results for
this closer portrait shot but the pixel
3a is actually slightly more detailed if
we punch in one thing that I noticed as
I was taking these portrait shots is
that the pixel 3a actually is faster as
processing these portrait shots then the
pixel 4 which doesn't make sense because
as a slower CPU now onto a wide sunset
shot the pixel 4 has a little bit better
dynamic range with more sky detail but
there's also a lot more noise in the
truck if we look at the photos metadata
the difference in ISOs is very minimal
that means the extra noise and artifacts
are coming out because Google is pushing
this old sensor to its limits to achieve
the greater dynamic range and if you
didn't know the sensor in the pixel 4 is
the same exact one that is in the pixel
3a and the pixel 3 shooting the sunset
selfie once again we see warmer tones on
the pixel for an exposed brighter for a
more pleasing looking image but the sky
is blown out and now switching to
nighttime the photos look very similar
you may notice that they're actually
flipped the pixel 4 is actually flipping
the images just like the iPhone now
instead of the previous pixels getting
into night mode shots I decided to put
the new 2 x telephoto against a 2 x
digital crap thinking that this should
show us a pretty good improvement but in
fact the difference is very minimal and
I was really shocked to see that we have
a little bit of difference in white
balance but both images look really good
I was also surprised to not see that
much of a difference here using the
standard lens in night mode but we see
the pixel 4 is actually slightly cooler
now and it seems like at night it
actually is often to go for a cooler
tone than before but the detail is very
similar that cooler wipeouts really
shows up in this
as well as the shadows being raised up
more and if we punch in we could see
that the pixel four has more detail
mainly because the ISO is lower or
because the pixel four is using a slower
shutter speed we also see a little bit
difference in dynamic range and also the
pixel four has more flaring with its new
camera square here's a night mode shot
of me they both look really good the 3a
has a little more saturation warmer
colors and slightly less details and we
pretty much get the same result in this
shots except for the pixel 3a looks like
it has slightly more details I took a
night mode shot in the sky thinking the
pixel four will bring out more stars but
it didn't but then when we're set up on
a tripod using the astrophotography mode
that automatically turns on we see a
massive difference the pixel four has
way more detail has way more stars in
the sky and it looks like a professional
full-frame camera using long exposure
compared to if we look at the sky the
pixel 3a has almost no stars and is
super mushy looking at the eye so we're
at 2198 compared to only 71 which is
like a daytime photo because the pixel
four took about two and a half minutes
to take this photo compared to just a
few seconds seeing this massive
difference in detail would make you
think that the file size would be much
larger but in fact no it is not looks
way better and the file is actually
smaller
here's another Astro shot even though
we're not shooting the sky this one is
about 90 seconds and the result in
detail is incredible now it's not as big
of a difference as before because we had
way more light but we're going from
something that looks like a great night
mode shot to something that looks like a
DSLR here's another Astro shot compared
to a standard night mode shot this one
doesn't have as huge of a difference
because it was the brightest but we
still see that we have a lot more stars
with a pixel four and more detail now
keep in mind you do need a decent tripod
in order for this night mode to show up
and this last one was a four and a half
minute exposure of course the actual
image is just sixteen seconds and they
combined a bunch of frames but look at
the stars in this shot it is incredible
and the detail is crazy as well very
clean pretty much no noise a DSLR could
not take this type of shot
unless you're doing long exposure as
well and it was pretty much pitch black
pixel 3a has a surprisingly usable image
for something that only took a few
seconds and in this kind of a situation
but it does not compare to the pixel of
fours now let's go inside and take a
couple more photos here I have a
portrait mode shot of a demon here we
can clearly tell the difference in white
balance where the pixel four is choosing
to go for a cooler tone make them look
kind of unnatural compared to the pixel
three A's warmer tone and we could see
the same thing right over here and now
it's time to finish up with some 4k
low-light footage in our office here
with the lights shut off and there we
have it you guys let me know does the
new pixel 4 have much better photo and
video quality than the budget pixel 3a
XL or does the budget device that comes
in at less than half the price keep up
surprisingly well I want to hear your
guys opinions down in the comment
section below go ahead and click above
to subscribe and down below to enable
notifications there's been max with max
tech and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]